>>Kevin Carle: Hi. Hello, everyone.
Welcome to WebM Open Video Playback in HTML5.
I have myself, Kevin Carle, here from Google.
Also Jim Bankoski.
And from Brightcove, we have Bob Mason.
And actually, also David Mendels.
>>Kevin Carle: You can follow along on wave
and ask questions and do Google moderator.
So, like I said, I'm a software engineer
at YouTube.
I work on latency and HTML5.
So today, we're going to cover couple things.
First off, we're going to go over a little bit
of an overview of HTML5 video,
go through some benefits --
what it does for us and for the user --
and go through some of what we've been doing
at YouTube with HTML5 in the last year.
And then, Jim's going to take it over
and start talking about WebM,
and we're going to go into some specifics
about "What is WebM and VP8 and performance"
and that sort of thing.
And then, we're going to
have some demos from YouTube
and Brightcove of WebM playing in our HTML5 players.
And then, some summaries of some of the experiences
we've had developing for HTML5 in the last year.
And then, we'll go to questions.
So what is HTML5 video?
So most of you probably know this stuff,
but essentially, HTML5 has introduced media tags
so that now we have audio and video as first-class
HTML tags along with everything else.
So now, the media player can be part of the browser
and you don't need a plug-in to be instantiated.
Otherwise, it acts like any other tag.
And you can see that the simplest possible
example of video tag is pretty much out there
that would start a little player using the browser's
built-in controls playing a video.
And one other thing I wanted to cover up front here
is just that we're going to be using the words
"codecs and containers" a lot.
Again, most of you probably know what that is.
But, for those who don't -- a "codec" is something
that encodes and decodes a video.
It's software that basically tells a video --
explains how the video's information
is organized and how to play it back.
A "container" is a file that wraps the video,
the audio --
other content associated with the media object --
and describes what it is and where it is.
So, what are the reasons that we want
the video tag in HTML5?
Well, the biggest reason is really
just that it's open.
So you now have the ability to have an open
source browser with a media player built in
and an open source video codec
and video container.
And so, now, anyone can implement the full stack
all the way from the video itself to the player.
And so, we'll have a lot of different implementations
out there and a lot of competition --
a lot of innovation in this space.
These next two reasons are fairly similar,
but there's a lot of opportunity for improvements
in latency and performance.
These will vary a bit, of course.
They're not guaranteed.
But for latency, for example, that you won't
have to instantiate and download a plug-in.
So at the very least,
you've got one pure resource request
assuming you package all your JavaScript
in CSS together the way it normally would.
And, depending on how the browser implements it,
you can get better performance,
assuming that they take advantage
of hardware and so on.
So, the other advantage, of course,
is the video tag is -- it's a video tag.
So, if you want to have a screen reader
or other accessibility software,
they know that it's a video and
they can handle it appropriately.
Some relief if you've got search indexer or
anything that's walking over the HTML page.
It knows it's a video and not just some sort
of plug-in where it doesn't know what's inside.
So, what have we been doing
with the video tag at YouTube?
Well, we've had a player up for a couple of months
now at YouTube.com/HTML5 using the h.264 codec.
As of today, we are announcing that
we have WebM videos available on the site.
For now, if you want to find WebM specific videos,
when you do a search, you can append
"and WebM equals one" to the search URL.
We'll clean that up a bit soon
and have a UI option for that.
As far as the browsers we support with HTML5,
it's pretty much everything at this point.
In Chrome, we now support h.264 and WebM.
WebM, of course, only on the newest Chromium build.
If you go to the Web M project website,
I believe there are links to all the browsers builds
that support WebM.
Safari, we support video tag with h.264.
Opera and Firefox, we will have support --
again, on those kind of tip-of-tree builds there
that have WebM support.
And that will be rolled out more later.
And then, IE9 -- we will have support
as soon as they release a preview
version essentially with a video tag
which should be in preview release 3.
And they would definitely support h.264.
And today, they announced they would be
supporting VP8 through direct show,
I believe, if you have that installed.
So that should give us quite a few options there.
We don't currently support certain advanced overlays,
like ads and annotations,
which are implemented in flash on our site.
We will be working on support
for those as time goes on.
We did just add this week -- caption support.
So, right now, it's actually
only the default caption track.
We still need to implement the menu
and selection and all that fun stuff.
But it should give you the default caption track
for your language if the video has captions.
And that's just on using JavaScript
and the Canvas tag for now.
So, looking at video formats
that we have at YouTube.
We support h.264 and WebM now.
Both formats are going to be supported
for uploads going forward.
For h.264, every video on the site
is basically be enabled on h.264.
We have then an MP4 container at three
resolutions -- 360p, 720p, and 1080p.
And then, in FLV container, we have
some additional formats like 480p.
Right now, there -- I don't know of any browser
that supports the FLV container in HTML5 tag.
Although there's nothing
really stopping them from it.
It is an open specification.
So if that ever happened, we could potentially
provide those additional formats in HTML5.
For WebM -- so, currently, we will be transcoding
all new 720p and above uploads in WebM.
We will eventually expand that
to all new uploads.
And we will also be going through and transcoding
our existing catalog of videos into WebM.
So it'll take a little while
as we get 24 plus hours of video a minute.
So, we'll be working on that.
So we currently have the WebM videos
available in 360p and 720p,
and we'll be adding additional formats over time.
So what can we not do with HTML5 right now?
Well, the biggest issue that people --
that users -- will notice I think is fullscreen.
So there is fullscreen support in web kit and in
Firefox.
Neither currently allows you to full screen anything
other than the video itself.
So the problem is -- if you want to be
able to implement your own controls
and things like the captions
which have been put into JavaScript --
those will not be available in fullscreen.
And then, many other browsers don't have
any current support for fullscreen.
Our short-term plan is that we're going to give you
the ability to expand the player to fill the browser.
That should be coming out soon.
And then, you can full screen the
browser or just maximize it or whatever.
We do hope that eventually
there will be some support for scriptable
and media element full screening in browsers.
So that you can implement --
take part of the page like in Canvas or something,
and expand it to full screen.
But we do don't know if that will happen.
Another issue is embedding.
So right now, most sites on the web, of course,
do video embedding through the object tag with flash.
So, that doesn't, you know, the object tag --
while, technically, it can be used for HTML5
-- it doesn't work very well.
It's not supported.
So really, iFrame is the best option.
Then, you can include the controls --
the JavaScript-- everything you need
to have your own player experience.
But the big issue with that, of course, is that not
everything allows you to embed in iFrame right now.
So we'll be talking with --
and working with --
sites in the community to push that kind of forward.
Live streaming -- there's no real spec
for live streaming right now in HTML5.
That's something that can come --
something that we've only recently
started doing ourselves.
Stream management -- so, right now, the browser
pretty much handles all of the aspects
of loading and displaying the video.
In Flash, you get a little more control over the
network streams and visibility into what's going on.
Some of that would be nice in HTML5.
It's not there now.
Content protection -- some content owners
rely on this to make their content available.
And right now, there's no official support
for this in HTML5.
And then, a big one is just that the
implementations and the spec are still in motion.
I'm sure a lot of web developers
are familiar with this kind of thing.
All the browsers are implemented
a little differently,
and there's still debate going on as
to how best to handle certain things.
So it just -- you know -- makes it a little extra fun
when developing.
And then, from a YouTube perspective,
we also have the issue of ads.
So, on a normal browser -- on desktop -- if you have
Flash, we can display the ads in Flash,
the video in HTML5 -- that's fine.
Obviously, some devices aren't going to have Flash.
And so, and those we won't be able to support videos
where the content owner requires ads.
And that's another thing that we just need
to work with the ad committee on essentially
is getting more content available in HTML5 for ads --
which is certainly doable.
Now, I'll turn it over to Jim to talk about WebM.
Jim Bankoski: Hi. I'm Jim Bankoski.
I'm an engineering manager at Google.
But, until recently, I worked at a small company
called On2 Technologies.
On2 was a pioneer in video codec technology.
We started in 1992 doing video game machines
like the Saga Saturn and the Saga Dreamcast.
We also did video and PC games like
Final Fantasy 7 and a bunch of other games.
Up until probably 2002 -- 2004, we were also --
we had a deal with electronic arts.
And we're in Sim City -- sorry -- Sims 2.
We're also -- around 2000, we started doing
Internet video with our site.
And we've been adopted since then by Flash --
so, our friends from Macromedia and Adobe.
And then, Skype and AOL Instant Messenger.
And now, in Java and Sun's Java effects.
Basically, we add up and we come to
a number around 2 billion installs
by summing up all the numbers
of the installs of these things.
In 2010, about two months ago, in February,
we were acquired by Google.
So it's been a very busy set of two months.
We went from our Codec -- where it was at On2 --
to released open source product today.
So you can imagine it's been a very busy
couple of months.
In any case, we're excited about what's happened.
And we talk about what WebM video is exactly.
WebM is kind of a container format that we
borrowed a spec from the core codec team
who created a format called "Matroska."
Matroska can contain video and audio
and some other things.
For us in the WebM spec, we're talking about
purely Vorbis audio codec and the VP8 video codec.
The Vorbis audio codec is from a team called "ZIF."
It's a great audio codec --
think very highly of it.
VP8 is a codec that we developed at On2
and is now what we open source today.
Move on.
So what's great about WebM?
We think the video quality is
great.
We think that you'll see that it's not blurry.
It's sharp.
There's not blocks.
We compare favorably with other codecs that are out.
We have strong playback performance --
or fast playback performance.
In other words, it'll play on your low-end processes-
your Atoms, your Snapdragons,
running on cell phones and the like.
We also have great, live,
2-way encoder performance.
I don't -- we mentioned on the last slide
that Skype was a user of ours.
We do very well in realtime performance.
Also, obviously, we're open.
And that means that anybody could download
and use it in any way that they see fit.
We think that that has a very --
some very unique advantages.
You won't be paying a royalty.
We're also -- we've also --
I'm sure you've seen --
we've got some great hardware
support coming out of the gate.
We have a lot of vendors that
have already jumped up and said,
"We're going to support this format."
We'll have a slide to talk about each of these.
I also -- sorry -- we don't want
to do short
shift.
We also have a lot of tools support from companies
like Sorenson and various others
who are providing encoders that
will produce our video format.
I keep calling it "our video format."
It's an open video format.
I'm going to talk a little bit about video quality.
This is a PSNR graph.
I'm sure very -- unless you've worked with video
before, you have no idea what this means.
So I'm going to talk a little bit about that.
There are two axes.
On the horizontal axis is "bitrate"
and "kilobits per second."
On the vertical axis is basically a metric of quality.
It's called "PSNR."
If you were to take a look at --
you follow along a straight line across --
you're basically saying
"All of these points have the same video quality."
So for us here, if you follow the fixed
quality across to about 2800 kilobits,
you'll see that VP8 achieved
on this clip a PSNR of 25.5.
Following the 25.5 line across,
you come to about 3400 kilobits for 264.
So, on this specific clip
with the settings that we used,
we got about 600 kilobit savings over the 264.
We've tested this on a lot of different clips.
At On2, we had about 70 clips that we were
typically using that cut from high def down to QCIF--
so that's high def being 1080p -- so 1920
pixels by 1080 high, 720p, 1280, 720,
all the way down to image sizes like 176 x 144.
We do very well, and we compare very favorably
against other codecs like 264, on a very wide set.
Now that we've become part of Google,
obviously, we have a much larger test set.
[chuckling] We can talk about hundreds
of thousands of videos as opposed to,
you know, the 70 that we're talking about now.
So. I'm just sliding through these.
I don't think anybody needs to, you know --
I can tell you that each one of the graphs
that I'm showing you is --
we are, in fact, comparing favorably.
But that is not to say that we always win.
There are clips that we are not doing as well on.
One thing we're also doing quite well on is,
playback performance.
But, there's a couple caveats
when I show these graphs.
First, the comparisons that we're doing --
I'm running in single core mode.
The codec does support multiple cores decoding.
But we haven't done a great job on that yet,
and we're going to.
I'll talk about some of the To Do's at a later point.
Another thing that I should mention is
the comparison is done in software.
We're not using hardware acceleration.
And there is some hardware acceleration
for 264 that are on PCs and cell phones today.
So I wanted to point that out.
Basically, we are about 20 percent --
oh, one final thing --
we haven't fully optimized our decoder yet.
We're not using the two most recent
instruction sets from Intel and AMD --
the SSE 2 instruction set
or the SSE 3 instruction set.
So we think that we can actually get a good boost
over where we are today in performance.
Right now, we have a couple of profiles.
Our Profile 0 -- which is our highest quality,
maybe slowest to decode --
is running about 15 to 20 percent faster than 264
and it's high-profile -- on high-profile material.
P1 -- which is our profile that competes well
with Baseline --
is actually slower today on the newest machines.
But we think -- and I'll show you another slide --
now that,
if you take SSE 2 and 3 out of the equation
by going to an older machine,
in fact, our Profile 1 is actually performing
faster than Baseline.
So I think you'll see that we are --
we compare very favorably to these codecs
on the playback performance side.
We also -- I don't want to skip over --
Atom is a very important possessor,
because it's used in a lot of netbooks today.
And Chrome OS will be supporting atom.
We are performing quite well on the Atom processor
in comparison to software decodes of 264.
Snapdragon is a processor that
uses an ARM neon instruction set.
It's in your Nexus 1 phones, if you have them.
We perform quite well.
We can just about do 720p in software.
As long as you're not doing anything else.
If you had to do audio decode in software
or something along those lines,
you'd have a little bit of trouble.
But we're very, very close.
I also mentioned earlier that
we do well at live compress --
live or 2-way compression.
We actually have inside of our compressor --
we have 16 different internal
complexities that we can switch between.
We can -- on a typical -- I think it was a 2-core --
we can run about 3 milliseconds per frame
for 640x480 software compress.
We can use as much as you're willing
to give up in terms of cycles --
up to somewhere around 45 milliseconds per frame.
So we'll get better quality if we spend more time.
The blue line in the back that you see
is actually a line
that describes our codec as of two months earlier.
I want to point that we've been rapidly
improving this codec.
And we think that there's quite a bit more
that we can do to improve it further.
I don't want to neglect our friends at ARM.
We also have an encoder for ARM processes.
This is that same Snapdragon.
And here we're basically able to do 640x480
at a 30 frames per second.
Again, using a hundred percent of the CPU right now.
We think we can do better,
but that's where we are.
I talked about another advantage being openness.
And I think Kevin hit on that.
Here's one way that you could contribute --
that's to go to our website --
WebMproject.org --
and download the
source code and start making check-ins.
We are very serious about the fact
that we want community involvement.
It is our plan to support two kind
of different bit streams --
one which will be bit stream compliant
and will stay with that bit stream
and another for experimentation
that's outside of the straight bit stream.
In that case, we're talking about wild ideas
that people have to improve the codec.
There's a lot of things that we
think that people could do--
the community could do.
There's -- for instance,
if you're familiar with digital cinema--
the people that do digital cinema do not use
typical RGB with 8 bits for R,
8 bits for G, and 8 bits for B.
They go up to 10 bits or even 12 bits.
That's something we haven't done in our codec yet.
That's a feature that we think that
somebody using our codec could add.
There's other things, obviously.
If you guys know about security cameras.
If you've ever seen dome cameras
where they're taking a picture, and the video is --
they're actually capturing through a dome,
so they get a 360 view.
We imagine that those guys have specific needs
around how the motion moves.
So we are very serious about our willingness
to accept contributions.
And we have kind of two tracks for doing that.
And I mentioned earlier that we have
a couple of things we haven't done yet.
Faster decoding is one of them.
We think that we can get very strong improvements
by doing some multicore stuff
that we haven't yet gotten in.
We haven't used the SSC 2 or SSC 3 instruction sets.
We haven't done much with GPU decoding yet.
All of these things are areas
that we are currently working on,
and we hope to get in soon.
We also think that we can improve the quality
of the codec in a lot of different ways.
There's features that we could add.
We also think -- one of the things
that we did in our release is --
our best quality mode is pretty darn slow.
We think we can do a lot better in our best
quality mode to make it a lot faster.
And that will have a good impact on people producing
the absolutely best quality that we have.
We also think that there's subjective quality
improvements that we could do.
Imagine that there's a person standing
in front of a screen
and there's white noise playing in the background.
Really, you want the compressor to do a good job,
potentially focusing on the person's face
as opposed to the stuff in--
the white noise in -- the background.
Our compressor right now doesn't
do anything like that,
and I think we could do a lot better.
And we have some internal features
that we are using --
we defined in the bit stream,
but really, haven't fully implemented
except in a researchy way.
In other words, we know that they're beneficial,
but we don't have them in our production build yet.
So we think that we can get a lot better
than we are today.
And we think we will in the short-term.
And we also hope that the community
will help us do this.
In terms of the browsers that support WebM --
if you sat through Sundar's keynote speech,
you saw that Mozilla Firefox will be supporting it.
Opera is supporting it.
Obviously, our own browser -- Chromium and Chrome --
will be supporting it.
And we're really hopeful that everybody else will.
I mean, we'd love to see Internet Explorer
and Safari on board supporting this.
All of this info you can find on WebMproject.org.
So you can go and find where to download these
browsers and to start playing with them.
We talked about industry support.
If you went to Sundar's keynote,
you saw this same slide.
There are a lot of software vendors--
people that are using it right out the gate
for things like video conferencing.
There are vendors that will be producing tools
that will let you encode in WebM.
There are also a lot of hardware
vendors.
And just -- I want to point out that --
just because a name doesn't appear
on the list doesn't mean that
they aren't working with us and moving forward.
There are a lot of people that are --
I think you'll see that in the coming days
that there will be more of these.
And I'm going to pass it over to Kevin again to
show you the demo of VP8 playing in YouTube.
>>Kevin Carle: All right, so you can see this is a --
the normal YouTube watch page --
if you opt in, like I said, to slash HTML5,
you can get the HTML5 browser
wherever your web browser will support it.
If you're on one that doesn't support h.264,
you'll want to see if for videos as WebM.
If you're on something, say Chrome,
you'll see it for pretty much all videos.
It's a nice little visual thing here so that
you can see if you're on HTML5.
We have the HTML5 logo, and we also have the WebM
logo when you're playing in the WebM format.
And that's just me not knowing
how to use a Mac. Sorry.
You can see it there.
This is the Chrome speed test video.
[lots of noises from the video]
The 1280x720 version.
[blasting sound]
[exploding sound]
And we updated the player this week.
If you've seen our flash player in the last
month or so, then it has this new look,
and we updated the HTML5 player this week to match.
So we have all the new controls here.
And videos with captions.
You'll see the captions and so on.
There's the new player.
>>Jim Bankoski: Okay, I would like
to introduce Dave Mendels.
>>David Mendels: Hi, I'm David.
Nice to meet you.
This is a cool event.
I want to thank folks at Google for having us.
It's exciting to be here.
It's exciting to be one of the partners
in the WebM announcement.
Is the microphone working?
I think that was human error,
not microphone error.
I was too far away.
I'll say again.
I'm David Mendels.
Thank you to Google for having us here.
It's a great event.
Really cool.
We're excited to be one of the partners
involved in the WebM announcement --
And I wanted to talk a little bit about video
and what Brightcove is doing
and what we're going to be doing with WebM.
So -- first of all,
when you think about video on the web,
there's lots of different problems to solve.
And a lot of people who haven't thought
about it and haven't published video think,
"Oh, it's just about playing a video."
You've got, you know, you need a video tag
or you need a flash player.
You need a play button, and you play a video.
And the fact is that the playback problem is
probably the simplest problem that people have.
There's a whole range of problems
that people have
when they want to do complex publishing
that involves video.
So, playback is the simplest problem.
But today, even that has become increasingly complex
because of the fragmentation of the runtime
environments -- whether you're --
Are you targeting flash?
Are you targeting HTML5?
Are you targeting both,
depending on which device you're on?
Are you doing different form factors
for different devices --
FlashPlayer 10.1, HTML5 and devices --
iPhone and iPad, etc.
And so, there's increasing complexity
even on the playback side.
Well, when we talked to our customers --
and we --
we're involved in publishing and streaming --
oh, I don't know -- on tens of thousands
of web properties,
hundreds of millions of videos,
billions of video plays a month.
The set of problems that our customers
are dealing with
and that we try to help our customers with are
much more than just playing back the video.
So how do you create an experience that you can
encapsulate and share into a Facebook stream?
How do you do subtitling and closed captioning?
How do you get analytics on that video?
How do you do engagement analytics?
How do you do audience demographics?
How do you do advertising insertions and prerolls
and midrolls and postrolls and overlays?
How do you do it with an ad network?
How do you do it with an ad server?
And I could go on.
There's just a wide range of things up here
that you have to do across a wide range of platforms.
And it's a complicated world.
There's a lot of fragmentation today
in what you have to deal with.
So briefly, what Brightcove is,
because some of you might know
who we are and some of you might not.
We're a Cloud-based, online, video platform.
So we've got the Cloud right there in the middle.
So what does that mean?
What we do for our customers is,
you upload a video to us.
And we take care of encoding it in the Cloud
into multiple renditions
at different bit rates and different codecs.
And then, we provide meta data management.
We will generate players.
We have a means of customizing those players --
integrating them with Twitter or with Facebook.
We have ways to integrate analytics --
both our own analytics as well as Google analytics
as well as other third parties
like Neilson or Omniture or Quantcast.
And then, we provide all of the hooks to integrate
with basically any ad technology out there
for video advertising on the web.
If you want to do that --
if you don't want to do that, that's great too.
And so, that's what we do.
And so, we solve that whole range
of problems end to end from,
"Hey I have a video. I want to play it.
I want to know who's watching it.
I want to monetize that with advertising,
and I don't want to manage all of that complexity
across different devices."
And on the playback side,
we do that across different screens --
so we do HTML5.
If you come to a device today from iPhone
or iPad and also Android or other devices--
we do flash.
And our aim is to make that process really simpler.
So every content publisher in the world doesn't also
have to manage this complex matrix of browsers,
Flash players, codecs --
but they can focus on publishing video
whatever their business model or communications
strategy is around publishing video.
And then, we can take care of detecting
that device, and going forward --
detect the device, detect the runtime,
and then, select the right rendition
and the right player to play back.
So our news today is pretty straightforward is that
we are adding to that mix of stuff we're doing,
support for WebM.
And somebody asked me earlier today,
"So why are you doing WebM?"
It's a pretty straightforward answer --
it's good, it's free, and it's open.
Not a very complicated story.
We think that's a great thing for the web.
Our whole business and our whole vision
resolves around
more and more people being able to publish video --
whatever video experiences they're trying to create--
whether that's personal or commercial,
whether it's entertainment or news
or any other kind of communication.
So the easier it is for people
to do that across devices,
across browsers across different experiences,
the better.
So we think WebM's a great thing.
We will still support h.264.
We support h.264 today.
And we'll do both across both Flash and HTML5
so that whatever device you're targeting,
you can get a great playback experience
and a great user experience.
So we're not interested in our customers
being collateral damage in the platform wars
among different vendors here who are fighting
for one platform or another.
Our take is,
"If you have video content to publish,
we will help you publish it.
We'll get it in the right format,
in the right device, at the right time."
And so, WebM will be a core part of that.
And we've already got it up and running.
It's in our Cloud-based encoding.
We'll have a demo to show you in a minute.
And that'll be available to all
of our customers later in the year.
And our customers --
just to give you some perspective --
range from Sony music,
that might be doing tens of thousands
of music videos,
to the New York Times or Fox Entertainment--
if you watch House or 24 or any of those shows--
all the way down to individual
churches or nonprofits.
So we range the whole gamut of customers.
And anybody interested in publishing
can take advantage of Brightcove
either through a set of user interfaces
or we provide rest-based APIs for everything we do.
So if you're a developer --
you're building applications,
you're building content management systems -- and
you want to integrate with a video publishing system
that will help you take advantage of WebM,
help you publish those players
without having to do all the work yourselves,
you can take advantage of the plumbing
we've basically built in the Cloud.
So that's what we do.
And the last piece is,
I just want to introduce Bob Mason.
Bob is our co-founder and CTO.
And we have a demo.
It involves playing some videos.
>>Bob Mason: Thanks, David.
What I want to illustrate here is a sample
application that we built as part of this effort.
What I wanted to sort of demonstrate is
this ability for us to do device detection,
understanding the capabilities
of the different platforms,
and then, actually rendering
out the appropriate experiences.
So, on my computer here I have a vanilla install,
a Firefox, Safari in one of the latest builds
of Chrome.
So if I go here to Firefox you can see
that this is a standard flash player.
Nothing remarkable or interesting
around that on its own.
But it gives great playback experiences,
and there's a huge amount of ecosystem
support on advertising integrations,
dynamic streaming playback.
It's a really robust delivery platform.
But if I now go to Safari,
what I want to sort of illustrate here is,
this is actually an HTML5 experience.
So as this page is getting loaded,
there's a series of rest-based APIs
and device detection code
that actually can determine
what capabilities this end user has.
And we're rendering out an HTML5 experience that
has high fidelity compared to a flash experience.
And you can see --
in this circumstance with this video --
that it's actually an h.264 video
that's being rendered in this circumstance.
But if I go to the Chrome version,
it's an identical HTML5 experience,
but the main difference here being is that we're
actually running VP8 video through this process.
So you can see it's actually working.
The way this system is managed the content
can get uploaded, encoded.
We actually store multiple renditions.
And then, the logic at the runtime is advanced enough
to understand the best way
to optimize the user experience based on
what device and what platform they're connecting to
and what capabilities.
Thank you.
[applause]
>>Jim Bankoski: And I think we're done
and it's questions now, right?
Kevin Carle: I have one more slide.
There we go.
All right, so we just had one quick slide here.
Just sharing some of the development experts
as we've had at YouTube,
and then, we'll lead right into the questions.
So one thing that might be helpful for anyone
who wants to play around with this in YouTube.
If you add the "&Debug=true."
We're using some closer stuff there to output
debugger information to law as you can see
what video formats are available for that video,
which one we've chosen for you,
all sorts of fun things.
You can also just --
if you want to go to HTML5 for a particular video,
you can add "&HTML5=true."
With all of these though,
including with the opt in --
which I don't think was entirely
clear in here earlier -- was that,
if the video was monetized,
we will still show you Flash,
because we have to show the ads.
And that's something we're working on.
Like so before if you want to find WebM videos,
you can add the "&WebM=1" parameter to your search.
And we'll probably have the UI option
for that under the advance search soon.
So some choices we've made in development --
we're not using a lot of the HTML5 semantic tags
for some of the video controls
such as like the progress element.
And this is because we have issues
around styling CSS support for those tags
and just general browser support.
But one nice -- but speaking of CSS,
one nice thing is that,
when you're working in HTML5,
you pretty much know you're working
in a modern browser
so we can use things like CSS 3 and a lot of things
where you don't have to worry so much
about supporting the older browsers.
One thing we've been working on is the whole
concept of the way we do fallback, content,
and source selection.
We don't actually use the source tags in the video.
Like, we don't render them out initially.
We actually do some JavaScript
before we create them,
because we want to be able
to have a little more control
over which source we choose based for the user.
And then, we also are working on
implementing the switch back to flash
on the client side if, for some reason --
even though we think on the server you'll be
able to use HTML5, but you really can't.
Like so, we're not making HTML5 default
for any browser yet, but that should be soon.
So one estimation of HTML5 is, of course,
it's supported on a lot of devices.
What you get is -- but the device support
is a little odd on many of them.
You don't actually get the controls and so on.
If there's a video element,
it'll actually full screen then the video element
automatically like on some phones, tablets, and so on.
So that's just something to keep in mind.
You won't always have that control
even if you do create the controls yourself.
One nice thing that actually got removed
to the UI this week with the action
is there's client side support for variable speed
playback in HTML5.
There's just a property called "playback speed,"
and you can set that to whatever you want.
We had that last week. It'll be back.
One thing that we found on seeking was
that it was better to pause the video,
do the seek, and then replay --
than to just seek.
That's something that maybe
that'd be fixed in some of the browsers.
But right now, we're getting a big performance
advantage to doing that versus
just issuing the "seek" command.
One other thing is that,
when we do the progress part rendering,
we originally were relying on the time update events.
But again, we found that a lot of browsers would
stop firing the time update events periodically.
This is probably a bug that'll get fixed.
But in the meantime, we actually have
a timer that fires every 500 milliseconds.
And if no time update events
have happened within that time,
we'll just go ahead and update
the progress part that way.
So we needed that fallback in order to keep
if from just stalling out much of the time.
So, we're going to open it to questions.
Also wanted to mention first that we have
a YouTube developer mixer tomorrow
at 6 p.m. at Jillian's across 4th street.
I'll have tickets for that that anyone can pick up
if they want in this chair over here.
And then, take a round of questions.
00:39:58.047,00:00:00.000